[Music]
three people accused in a theft ring at
a charter school are no longer in jail
the bail amount was drastically dropped
so this is the story the eight news now
i-team first broke vanessa murphy
continues coverage of the felony
criminal case with this latest twist in
court
judge susan bockham initially set bail
at nearly 154 thousand dollars but now
bail for two of the defendants is
reduced to just a fraction of that and
they're no longer in custody here at the
clark county detention center that 154
thousand dollars is the amount which
metro police say was stolen this was
kovitt 19 relief money for school
projects which detectives say the
teachers spent on themselves it appears
victoria welling posted that original
bond and is continuing her case in las
vegas justice court she's accused of
approving the fraudulent transactions
last year when she was principal at
legacy traditional school southwest
campus which is a charter school
teachers christopher olmsted and andrea
fuentes soto waived their right to a
preliminary hearing the case heads to
district court and the clark county
district attorney's office and defense
attorneys agreed on much lower bail
amounts for fuentes soto it's just more
than 36-hundred dollars for olmsted it's
just more than 4 200 dollars according
to court records prior to this before
the bill was lowered olmsted submitted
an emergency filing arguing that higher
bail wasn't fair the teachers are
expected to be back in court monday the
principal is expected in october
reporting in downtown las vegas vanessa
murphy live local now